seven folds seven wizards but long ago
which was a champion and with choice
right costly he used these powerful
revenge releasing the seven deadly
scenes into the world welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my new Black Adam movie video in just a
society video that's right we're gonna
get a movie DC EU version of the Justice
Society so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for the Black Adam
movie on the video you just have to
imagine the rock pounding every single
member of the Justice Society and we
finally have a basic plot synopsis for
the Black Adam movie so just starting
with number 5 as you would expect the
movies supposed to begin with a really
big action set piece set in the distant
past explaining all the stuff that the
wizard told to Billie in that magical
PowerPoint presentation explaining how a
warlord kills his wife and child during
an attempt to conquer Kondik in black
adam isn't able to save them he blames
the council of wizards for not using
their power to save them that leads him
to this moment where he releases the
seven deadly sins then black adam turns
on the magical council killing all them
except for the wizard and according to
the most recent synopsis of the movie
whatever version this is going to be the
wizard winds up teaming up with the
original version of the Justice Society
in the past to stop Black Adam and trap
him in a magical prison that they think
is for all eternity
so apparently there's supposed to be two
different versions of the Justice
Society during the movie one set in the
distant past with the original
characters then number four closer to
present-day he escapes his tomb and
seeks to resurrect his wife and take
back conduct from the warlords who
control it but because he's so hardcore
he leaves a trail of bodies in his path
in the Justice Society in present-day
are closer to present-day have to reform
to stop him the only real big Justice
Society characters that I've heard about
so far are the Alan Scott Green Lantern
and dr. fate in both the Hawks Hawkman
and Hawkgirl they don't mention every
single team member that's going to be on
that original version of the team
but I think they're gonna try and be
relatively comic-book authentic the one
really big change that I am expecting
them to make is just to omit Wonder
Woman because technically she was a
founding member of the Justice Society
in the comics but because of Wonder
Woman 1984 and all the stuff they're
doing with gal gadot movies they'll
probably just leave her out of that
equation but she was around for all this
world history so maybe they'll find some
funny way to reference her in the past
like there is a Wonder Woman out there
somewhere according to the most recent
reports the version of the Justice
Society closer to present-day would be
more like atom smasher a version of
Cyclone there have been rumors about a
version of star girl but I don't know
about that because of what's going on
with the star girl TV show then you have
characters like the Hawks that
reincarnate Hawkman Hawkgirl then you
have characters like dr. fate who
technically don't die dr. fate is just a
title that's given to whoever is wearing
the helmet of fate but you get the basic
idea the movie opens with the big action
set piece set in the past were there
able to fight him to a standstill but he
manages to escape closer to present day
and they have to fight him back again
but because he's not supposed to be the
main villain of the movie that's how
they positioned the Warlord's in conduct
as being way worse so he comes off as
more of an antihero like Mel Gibson and
payback or Keanu Reeves in John wick
still bad to drop so many bodies but
they killed his dog so you get why he's
going so biblical on everyone it just
did in the case of the Black Adam movie
they killed his family
so three after he liberates conduct
they're supposed to be a truce of sorts
with the Justice Society members and
they set up the eventual Shazam
crossover movie in a future post-credit
scene that follows up on the events of
the first Shazam post-credit scene with
mr. Mayan and dr. sivana
[Laughter]
when mr. mind is talking about wanting
to control the seven realms of magic
that's all stuff that's gonna serve as
the main story for Shazam - and that
movie is coming out after Black Adam but
unless something really big changes down
the road Zachary Levi has said black
Adam wouldn't actually crossover with
them until Shazam three or whatever they
want to call that movie
Shazam versus black Adam would be a
solid pick unless they're afraid to use
that title for some reason because of
Batman V Superman the reason why they're
using just to Society for the Black Adam
movie in not Justice League obviously is
because all those actors are busy doing
other stuff the Justice League actors
enable the Snyder cut stuff coming up
like all the others
[Music]
I had a dream but black Adam has spent
most of his time interacting with the
Justice Society Geoff Johns actually did
an early two-thousands run if you want
to read up on Black Adam Justice League
stuff that's a good place to start and
it also seems like they're gonna be
pulling a little bit from black out of
the Dark Age which is the story of him
trying to resurrect his dead wife number
two also at the end of the Black Adam
movie they also set up a potential
Justice Society spin-off movie with
those characters you probably heard the
news that Warner Brothers is considering
making a Justice Society movie but it'd
be based on the characters from the
Black Adam movie right now there's no
plot synopsis for what that would be
or which other characters they'd involve
or who the villain of that movie would
be right now the news is Warner Brothers
are just gonna wait to see how
everything goes with the Black Adam
movie and if they like those characters
the way they're treated if fans respond
well to them then they'll pursue an
actual Justice Society movie but right
now it's really just an idea in their
heads recently you also probably saw the
video that I posted a couple days ago
the star girl series on the DC streaming
service just debuted a version of the
Justice Society featuring Joel McHale of
all people I never would have expected
him to start one of the DC series
I told you to wait if you're going by
crisis on Infinite Earths multiverse
rules their version of the team is from
earth-2 because the Justice Society in
the comics is from earth-2 we never
actually found out what number the
designation of the Justice League
DC EU earth was when Ezra Miller's flash
showed up but that would be the same
universe that the Black Adam and Shazam
characters come from since those movies
are connected to Justice League like a
really good example we're talking about
Henry Cavill Superman possibly coming
back for a Man of Steel 2 now because of
all the Snyder cut Justice League stuff
Billy Batson Shazam character already
canonically knows Henry Cavill Superman
so if that wasn't clear this is meant to
be Henry Cavill Superman the reason why
you don't see his face it was just
because of a scheduling problem but he's
wearing Henry Cavill suit it's meant to
be him so therefore by association the
Black Adam movie is also connected to
the Justice League movies I know
everyone wants to see Superman go up
against Black Adam at some point if
we're talking about Henry Cavill and
negotiating a new contract to play
Superman in a couple of different movies
it'd be amazing to see him cameo in one
of the Black Adam sequels in a long time
ago when the rock was still trying to
develop the movie before they'd
announced a release date
boss logic who does a lot of fan art
said he was contacted by the rocks
people to do some fan art of him
fighting Superman when he was developing
the movie with Warner Brothers in Gimli
so it sounds like the rock has been
talking to Warner Brothers about using
Superman in one of his future Black Adam
movies now obviously I don't think we
expect him to show up in the first
blackout a movie but just the idea that
it could be possible now that Henry
Cavill is coming back I think is amazing
in number one I know a lot of you are
also asking if any of these Justice
Society characters would show up in the
Justice Society movie or the Black Adam
movie because if they're talking about
star girl we have a version on the TV
shows now my assumption right now is
that that's gonna be treated separately
and they'll just recast different actors
and they'll try to avoid duplication but
like there's a version of dr. fate
that's supposed to show up during Black
Adam but there's also supposed to be a
version of the characters showing up on
the star girl TV series I think they'll
just expect fans to understand the
difference when they see both versions
and it's still gonna be a while before
we see the Black Adam movie
it's just one of those things where you
have like the TB Grant Gustin flash and
then you have the Ezra Miller movie
flash just expected to be a little bit
like that no I'm also the flash those
are the what the flash flash flash if it
wasn't clear from crisis on Infinite
Earths why the Ezra Miller flash didn't
know that he was called the flash why
that seemed like a brand new thing for
him it's because during all of his
appearances in the DC movies in Justice
League and Suicide Squad no one ever
called him to flash he wasn't actually
gonna get that name to the flash movie
which is still happening at this point
even though there's not really any big
news updates on the flash movie right
now other than they're doing a version
of flashpoint but everyone let me know
in the comments what are you most hyped
up about for the Black Adam movie or any
potential Justice Society movie if we
get any more news about that of course
I'll include it in one of my videos
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel used to see all the
videos when I post them but everyone
click here to rewatch that Justice
League Snider cut teaser trailer and
click here for my brand new Marvel
Wolverine video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you